é mas ela ao mesmo tempo diz que tudo
vai mudar
É porque ela vai ser o que quis
inventando um lugar
E aí
é a primeira vez que eu ouvi com
profundidade os versos de tigresa do
Caetano Veloso eu era adolescente indo
para Minha Vida Universitária
é aquele lugar de criar um novo espaço
de transformar de inventar tudo aquilo
me parecia maravilhoso porque quando a
gente se sente meio deslocado meio fora
do Fora do Eixo fora do ninho tudo fica
meio estranho sabe mas quando a gente
cria esse novo espaço a gente não
precisa ficar naquele exercício difícil
de se adequar de se encaixar nos padrões
e estereótipos nas Convenções sociais
porque no fundo a gente acaba não
fazendo parte de nada
quem sabe aquela expressão das antigas
nossos pais nossos avós quando ele falou
que inventar moda é uma coisa ruim então
para mim inventar moda foi Libertador
para mim individualidade
a entender meu corpo entender minha
corporeidade entendendo a minha estética
elas foram fundamentais para que eu me
sentisse poderosa autoconfiantes forte
Ah e não abaixasse a cabeça nos lugares
em que ocupavam
e olha quero lugares muito solitários Em
vez dele entrar naquela do eu não sou eu
não posso não é para mim eu escolhi o eu
agrego eu sou necessária eu somo eu
pertenço
Ah e quando eu era novinha criança
adolescente o meu principal livro não
tinha capa e nem sequer folha ele ficava
localizado no fim das galerias
comerciais ou nos becos e vielas das
periferias e o nome dele era salão de
beleza afro
É sim esse espaço ele me trouxe um senso
de pertencimento muito importante porque
foi lá aonde eu tive referências de
autoridades políticas artistas médicos
empresários pretas e pretas no poder e
isso me ajudou muito na minha construção
de imagem e autoestima porque eu entendi
que moda que estética é mas eram mais do
que uma roupa só mais do que algo vazio
algo fútil
o amor é uma ferramenta de expressão e
de fortalecimento e talvez essas
experiências foram os mais importantes
em termos de aquilombamento das que tive
eu cresci Numa família muito acolhedora
muito amorosa e com muito espaço de
opinião senso crítico e muito
desbravador a minha mãe Educadora
formado em psicopedagogia e meu pai
advogado Engenheiro Eles talvez não
tiveram aquela oportunidade de ler
livros sobre debate racial ou estudar
teórico negros pensando que era década
de 60 e 70 quando eles eram os primeiros
negros da família a entrar nesse espaço
Acadêmico
É mas ele sentiram literalmente na pele
como é você ocupar um lugar fazer tudo
que o sistema que exige que é ter estudo
educação formação boa Apresentação mas
ainda assim não fazer parte dele
Oi e aí décadas depois com tanto
autoconhecimento tanta consciência eu
achei de fato que o meu método tigresa
iria decolar
eu estudei em boas universidades morei
fora estudei 4 idiomas tudo para dar
certo
Oi e aí cheguei na minha carreira no
começo a minha jornada com moda eu vi
que esse ela vai ser o que quis e
ventando um lugar ele até existia mas
não tinha mulheres negras desse
protagonismo
a trabalhar com os maiores nomes da moda
Nacional ocupar as principais empresas
do setor escrever nos principais
veículos tudo isso é maravilhoso muito
bom eu me orgulho muito mas ainda falta
um pouquinho porque eu sentia que aquilo
dali não ia validar minha jornada por
completo
Oi e aí eu entendi que moda para mim não
era só sobre look sobre o bom desfile
mas era sobre entender as pessoas negras
desse setor apontar de lacunas da
invisibilidade estabelecer conversas e
entender que o mais importante de tudo é
nós contando a nossa própria história
E aí eu vi que eu não era apenas uma
reprodutora de formatos
é mas uma pessoa que constrói a sua
linguagem e que cria o seu lugar no
mundo diariamente criar os seus espaços
inventar fazer acontecer e tudo isso sem
medo de errar e evoluindo mas sem
aqueles receios do preconceito ou do
julgamentos é isso é muito importante
porque a gente sempre tá com aquela
pretensão de ter que fazer quatro vezes
a mais do que o mundo inteiro
e isso é tudo que uma mulher como eu
mulheres negras como eu querem pessoas
vidas querem sentir
é porque a representatividade Sim ela
abre portas mas o pertencimento ela é
aquele tapete no hall de entrada por
seus sonhos EA sua vontade de criar
novos espaços e isso eu gosto de chamar
de pertencimento circular
é e qual é o poder desse pertencimento
circular ele é a evolução da nossa
ocupação e representatividade é nós
Assumimos todas as pontas da estrutura
desde os cargos de entrada até hoje
liderança é a gente criar o que nos
convém e nos sentimos confortáveis com
isso é como naquela metáfora mais do que
só ir para festa o pertencimento
circular ele te convida para dançar te
leva para pista de dança e no final de
tudo você ainda tira os sapatos porque
você sentiu muito acolhida pelos seus
novos amigos
Ah e falando um pouquinho saúde mental
tem um estudo na universidade de
Washington do pesquisador Dean Anderson
que o pertencimento é muito importante
para pessoas negras em ascensão social
porque quando a gente não se sente parte
o que acontece é que nós somos muito
mais acometidas pelo stress e pela
problema de saúde e por isso que eu
acredito nesse novo lugar de
pertencimento mas como criar esses
locais seguros para pessoas negras como
entrar nesses lugares de prestígio
social e ainda se conciliar com a imagem
com autoconfiança autoestima
principalmente nós mulheres negras
é um passo importante é a conexão com a
nossa ancestralidade no meu caso a moda
foi fundamental Porque a partir dela eu
consegui saber mais sobre a minha
história eu entendi o poder da minha
Imagem e do meu intelecto e ainda assim
fique com que não só eu mas com que
outras pessoas tivessem transformações
grandiosas com ocupação desse espaço
e o segundo passo é ter um olhar
inovador para imaginação e para coragem
porque às vezes a gente vai procurar
lugares que ainda nem existem a gente
precisa ter Muita criatividade para
pensar nesses espaços e coragem porque a
gente vai ter medo a gente vai achar que
não vai ser aceito a gente vai querer
aprovação de tudo e de todos mas não é
por aí que tá tudo bem Tem medo mas é
com medo mesmo que a gente vai
o interesseiro a comunidade é tudo crê
nisso de acolhimento não só para você
mas também por seus é sobre hackear os
espaços é sobre inventar um lugar e
fazer com que as pessoas sejam acolhidas
e tem um vozes ativas E é isso que eu
faço na minha plataforma mequetrefismos
porque é muito importante não só o
pertencimento mas também o protagonismo
ea pluralidade
é bom caminhando um dia desse pela rua
eu fiquei observando as status que
tinham dos heróis da nossa história bom
todas as pessoas que eu não me sinto
pertencente ou que estão muito longe do
meu convívio
e eu entendi a importância da moda na
cidade porque Diferentemente daqueles
monumentos de frios estáticos com trajes
uniformizados a moda ela circula ela
pertence ela é viva
Oi e a importância do pertencimento
Circular é que mais do que entrar em
caixas que grupos opressores tanto
insistem e nos colocar é exercer o nosso
espaço de liberdade
a representatividade importa o
pertencimento ele humaniza
bom obrigada
E aí